egan thompson out there for his second
career start you go back and look at
that first one it started out a little
bit rough settled down started taking
some deep breaths the next thing you
know he got into the fourth inning
without letting the dodgers of course
the reigning world series champion score
he goes the other way and up the line
and that's going to be down
hayward plays the high bounce well and
whit will hold
with a single
he was able to reach it
great head position let the ball travel
all those good things
mainly
it fell fair
nicki was hitless yesterday
slider and that's going to be up the
line and you can hear the royals fans
roaring as whit
will go first to third
and nikki lopez has a double
hold it sharply no chance for frank the
tank to even get a glove on it
carlos was over three with a walk
yesterday
and that cutter's way inside it hits the
bricks
and whit will score
lopez goes to third and with nobody out
yet the royals lead one nothing three
and two second and third one nothing
royals
left field going back
is hermeseo and hauls it into the track
a long inning
for keegan thompson
wow how about that you know bowitch this
is a good opportunity for him now he's
got a run before he even tows the slab
here
and a fastball puts him away so a good
start for bubitch
and one down in the first
wit singled up the right field line in
the first inning and then scored on a
wild pitch
ground ball right side and that's going
to be a diving play by bodhi and not in
time
and now nikki lopez and he lines it over
the shortstop duffy and into left center
field
so the royals get a hit with a runner in
scoring
position nikki is two for two rivera
scores and the royals lead two nothing
in the second boy what a pretty swing
this is that's what he wanted to do
center cut short swing under control put
the ball and play in the big part of the
field good things happen
line to left field but slicing and ben
and tendy made a great play
and it helped that the ball was slicing
in his
direction and there are two down
i mean he started out at 100 speed and
caught right in the end of his
fingertips there and is able to hold on
and that's not where
cam gallagher wanted that either he
wanted that pitch up but it was down and
hayward thought he had extra bases here
andrew benintendi was a big out for
thompson in the first inning that he
sits on this pitch right here
good call
yeah that's gonna roll
deep so he took a nice easy swing on a
fastball up
and ben attendees at second base with
nobody out
ground ball to first backhanded by
schwendell with a dive feeds thompson on
the bag good play advancing to third ben
intended nice play by schwendell dove to
his right to make the play
change up strikes him out so bubbitch
doesn't let schwendel get away this time
beautiful location
gets the hitter out front and you make
him look like that now the o2 to wisdom
swinging in a miss back-to-back
strikeouts in the inning
change-up
and he got him so he did pull it
together and he strikes out the side and
bubic has seven strikeouts
in four hitless innings
he is on top of his game
attendees struck out in the first inning
and then he doubled leading off the
third
pulled and into right field for a base
hit
so ben attendee has gone the other way
and he has pulled the ball for his two
hits
michael a taylor the royal center field
pulled to left field and that's going to
be down and into the ivy
ben and tendy to third he stumbled
coming around third and the relay to the
plate is going to be in time
well andrew benintendi is clearly out at
home plate however the royals are
challenging and
challenging whether
chirinos blocked the plate and
the royals are going to win the
challenge we haven't seen this one in a
while but
because of the new rule the catcher
cannot block the plate chirinos did not
provide a sliding lane
for andrew benintendi
and if you go back
and you look at where chirinos was
before the throw was made
now catcher as long as he provides
a lane
if the throw
causes him to go in a position where he
blocks the runner that's okay but
he was in front of the plate the whole
time yeah that's a good call so
mike matheny and cal eldred depending on
the circumstance might
stretch him out a little bit today
it's one in the third inning
breaking ball is
pulled out to whitmer field and that is
six hitless innings for chris bubinch
and whit hits it well into right center
field and that'll drop in front of
hayward both of
whitt's hits to the outfield have been
to right yeah nice little soft step kept
his head right there an easy swing
and the ground ball is into center field
that's base hit number three for nikki
lopez
whit goes to third
so nikki is three out of four and here
come the royals with runners
at the corners and nobody out
lopez runs again
that's a foul tip
and a throw
over
second base and on the throw merrifield
comes down from third
so chirinos
went for nikki lopez and the royals
execute a double steal
the tarp was put on the field there was
no rain boobitch stayed loose
in the bullpen and it'll be about a 30
minute
no rain rain delay and here comes
patrick wisdom old for two with a fly
out and a strikeout
drilled left field that one towards the
corner number 20 patrick wisdom
breaks up the shutout the no hitter
and the cubs on the board it is 4-2
yeah that was the change-up and wisdom
stayed back and he hammered it
nikki lopez is doing his best to remind
him
of what he's accomplished today
with merrifield the same emanuel rivera
cam gallagher
and now mike matheny
on the ground right side santana will
take it himself and the royals have
another good day at wrigley field
they win today
4-2
with terrific pitching again led by
chris bubich
you